right but just picture the scene imagine
this was a movie right that it's a
four-year movie it's the 4th of July
2015 this the last day we give people
off it's a Saturday
they're like home with their families we
got a skeleton crew in right and this
problem develops the spacecraft while
we're receiving signals also goes
offline never happened in nine and a
half years of flight ok dead silence
getting phone calls so everybody gets
phone calls if I will start coming in
entry gets activated right of course
every but its fourth of July so they're
like by the pool grill and their burgers
right right so so people start coming
they don't know what they're coming in
for they don't know if they're coming in
it might be for an hour - we need a
meeting something's up
turns out they were there for days on
end yeah and and you you have to picture
this team of like super intelligent
driven flight controllers and engineers
and scientists and managers and
everybody's in flip-flops and shorts
right you tank tops and you're like
saving a space mission on the doorstep
of Pluto three billion miles away and we
look like we just all walked in for
picnics right and for three days nobody
went home it's like this
around-the-clock forget about having a
shower right I mean we started phone
train calling even or like all the
assistants the Secretary's staff to just
come like make runs to you know fast
food restaurants yeah people did not
leave for three plus days but the end